it's breakfast and eggs guaranteed to
spice up your day
some of the best food i had in india was
street food
and
every little food stall
was cooking up something spicy something
delicious
a teaspoon
of oil gonna toast off
a teaspoon
of cumin
mustard seeds
a touch of salt
and pepper
lightly fry them off
it's really important to cook off the
spices
it intensifies the flavor but really
draws out that nice spicy deep rich
flavor so
onion three fingers one in front two
behind nice and fine
onions in
[Music]
now
we're going to caramelize those onions
mustard seeds have
started to infuse
cumin has that nice kick
now with a little touch of butter in
there get it nice and sort of rich
gas up nice and high
and really caramelize those onions now
once the onions have turned a rich
golden color that's what i'm looking for
that is beautiful
add baby spinach
keep that pan nice and hot
if you don't cook it out
the actual breakfast ends up watering
when the spinach is cooked set aside and
it's on to the spicy eggs
now the breakfast really starts to come
alight
four nice eggs
now give those eggs
a little whisk a little touch
of butter
into the pan a little teaspoon
of oil so the butter doesn't burn when
the butter and oil are hot add a
teaspoon of garam masala and turmeric
cook that out
now
take your eggs
into the pan
almost gonna make
like a really nice spicy scrambled egg
turn the gas down
now as the scrambled egg comes together
just finish that with a little bit of
butter
i quite like the sort of creaminess
makes it so much more delicious
and then from there
i get my spinach
chop up
and then fold in
the spinach
to your scrambled egg
something quite exciting about eating
spice for breakfast but it's served in
these wonderful little
thin naan breads
this will work with any flatbread or
wrap you fancy and then lightly toast
your naan take the eggs off the heat
whilst you get on with the last job add
quick mint and spice yogurt dressing
couple of tablespoons
of fresh yogurt in there's always
something take out the heat then add
chopped mint
salt and turmeric
mix that in
now
take
a scrambled egg and half fill
and now
it smells incredible get your yogurt
down on top and lift that over
and for me that's what really stands out
with street food in india
how delicious they can make street food
with a little bit of spice
amazing
[Music]
once you try this spicy wrap i promise
you scrambled eggs will never taste the
same
a punchy breakfast of murgues and
fontina stuffed croissants
flavor there is incredible
for lunch a spicy mexican soup be
adventurous but beware
serve with quick tortilla chips and a
peek of the gaio dip
meggy
for dinner i'll be setting the world to
right with my eldest megan
you're so annoying i'm so annoyed when
we make one of the favorite dishes
crispy roast duck with pancakes and
black bean dipping sauce
cena's is your favorite that you can
make it
followed by a spiced banana tart to tan
wow
these are my ultimate recipes for a day
bursting with a big and bold breakfast
lunch and dinner
starting with a breakfast that can't
fail to wake you up
murguez and fontina stop croissants okay
big and bold i was living in france i
stayed there for three years
once twice a week i treated myself to
the most amazing
bold breakfast and it started off with
these beauties here murgays cheap but
incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan
mug is in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't even chili
just a touch
of salt and pepper
you can smell
the spice they started to release all
that wonderful oil that flavor in there
add a couple of cloves i'll finely slice
garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark rich
golden color
now take a look at the heat out with the
parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavour during cooking but the leaves
should always be added just before
serving to give maximum colour and
fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing
all right
beautiful
now
take your quest on they're literally 24
hours old so they're crispy on the
outside and just slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
i used to cringe when i saw the french
cooks throw away croissants i used to
cry thinking oh my god
any idea what you're throwing away in
terms of flavor
whatever you do do not wipe out that pan
dunk your croissants mopping up all that
amazing flavor and caramelizing the
inside
for that beautiful and don't forget the
lids
and then get your thumbs and go inside
the croissant
all i want to do now is just create a
little pocket
and just manipulate the question now
this is where it gets exciting
mix up
the capers the garlic and sausages
look at the color
of that wonderful
delicious flavoured oil now some cheese
but not just any cheese fontina cheese
is like the number one cheese for
grilling and because it's a very rich
cheese you shave it thinner than you
would a white truffle but it gives a
really nice saltiness and a light smoky
flavor
a little touch of pepper
salt
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds
on the grill
here we go
nice
crisp
packed full of flavor
now top them
and that for me
it's almost like being back in paris
except this time
i don't have to share them with the
french
my ultimate big and bold breakfast
murgies and fontina stuffed croissants
the perfect picnic breakfast my ultimate
scotch eggs with a twist
[Music]
i go fishing a lot and scotch eggs are
the perfect all-in-one mini picnic
breakfast
first thing get your eggs cooked bring
the water up the boil onto the spoon
and lower them into the water that way
they don't hit the water and crack
four and a half minutes that will keep
the center
nice and slightly runny now
ground sausage meat i'm gonna make mine
a little bit spicier i'm gonna crumble
in black pudding
that helps to season the scotch eggs
inside a little touch of salt and pepper
and then just to make it a little bit
sweeter and a lot easier for the kids to
eat some grated apple
[Music]
combine that blend in the apple and the
black pudding
eggs once they're cooked drain them and
then run them under cold water
cracking and cooling the eggs quickly
will prevent the yolks turning gray
tap them on the side of the pan
put them back into the water and what
happens the water seeps underneath the
shell
see the shell come off so much easier
eggs still slightly soft in the center i
want that little bit of richness with
the yolk
next you need to get yourself organized
with a mini assembly line
seasoned flour
a little egg wash
and bread crumbs
take
your mince golf ball size
spread the pate manipulate with your
thumb
and then
sit your egg in there
and spread
the sausage over the egg and you just
seal that over
it's really important to keep that nice
even coating of sausage meat around the
egg you don't want it too thick
otherwise it gets too dense and it's
unappetizing
give them a light dusting in the
seasoned flour
if you don't put the flour on the egg
wash won't stick if you don't put the
egg wash on the breadcrumbs won't stick
into the egg
roll it round
shake off
any excess egg wash and roll it into
your breadcrumbs you can use this same
three-stage method to breadcrumb
anything you'd like from chicken goujons
and fish fillets to fina schnitzel
these are panko breadcrumbs japanese
white breadcrumb so no crust
you can experiment by adding flavors to
your breadcrumbs like parmesan herbs or
citrus zest
i always like to push the actual
breadcrumbs into the sausage meat so it
gets that really nice golden brown and
stops any of the outside burning
once bread crumbs lower the eggs
carefully into a four centimeter deep
bath of hot vegetable oil for 10 to 12
minutes
the eggs are actually cooked
soft and running the center so the
objective is just to cook the sausage
meat and the black pudding
they look great don't they go and
grenades
there's something so magical about a
scotch egg on a picnic because it's like
this little mini breakfast
beautiful
drain them onto the paper roll them
around
just to get off any excess oil and then
to transport them
some greaseproof paper
that for me is the perfect start to the
fishing trip there's no wonder i never
catch any fish
because i'm always too busy eating my
scotch eggs
[Music]
my ultimate black pudding lace scotch
eggs an irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast